je suis arrivé sur le plateau et puis il
me parlait tout ça et je vais juste dire
on ferait de beaux enfants ensemble je
ne sais pas d'où c'est sorti mais c'est
sorti comme ça vous êtes capable de dire
des trucs pareils
alors vous êtes né le 6 octobre 1962 à
Nice alors vos parents c'était connus
très jeunes et quand vous naissez votre
père est encore en train de faire ces
études d'ingénieurs et votre mère est
vendeuse mannequin chez TIC tuner à Nice
sans rencontrer on a offert du ski à
Auron parce que quand on est jeune à
Nice on va faire du ski à 15 ans et
voilà ils sont mariés très jeune donc je
suis arrivé papa et partait au service
militaire ok il a échappé au départ à la
guerre d'Algérie parce que j'étais le
deuxième enfant voilà
réalise son rêve en entrant à EDF très
vite il se fait muter à Paris et là vous
quittez Nice à ce moment là ça a été un
vrai des racines pour moi alors votre
père fera toute sa carrière à EDF et
votre mère s'orientera vers des
boutiques de fringues un peu petit des
brocantes
parfois un peu la honte au lycée parce
que il y a eu toutes les époque Krishna
et alors nous on arrivait avec les
doudounes les premières doudounes mais
qui n'étaient pas enfin qui était
vraiment brute qui se sentait très fort
le bouc avec les nattes et tout ça et
voilà on montrait un peu ce qui se
vendait dans la boutique c'était quand
même très puissant de Love
vous dites on était copains copines une
éducation très libre mais moyennement
une éducation dites-vous en fait mes
parents ils ont pas vraiment été éduqués
je dirais c'est à dire que ils ont
beaucoup souffert de la guerre en fait
dans le nord de la France a été la
maison occupée par les Allemands le père
en déportation etc donc il le père de ma
mère qui est mort en 40 donc ensuite
quand ils sont connus à Nice ils étaient
quand même en deux familles assez
traumatisées et sont connus tous les
deux et en se disant on va faire notre
vie ils ont coupé avec la famille
famille et ils avaient ils avaient 20
ans ils ont eu des enfants à 21 22 ans
qui est deux enfants étudiants et en
fait eux-mêmes n'ayant pas été vraiment
structuré et éduqué ils nous ont laissé
ils ont vraiment pour eux 68 ça a été la
découverte totale est vraiment et donc
c'était on n'empêchera jamais rien aux
enfants du coup ne pas avoir de limites
pas avoir de nom ça construit pas non
plus totalement on sait qu'on en est un
peu revenus au lycée vous êtes une élève
très douée vous avez votre bac à 16 ans
grec ancien oui je fais 11 ans de grec
anciens et en fait j'ai adoré le grec
ancien la philosophie la tonicienne tout
ça puis voilà et donc j'ai passé mon bac
avec à 16 ans à 17 ans vous faites
hippocaigne à Louis-le-Grand il vous
obtenez une maîtrise de lettres à la
Sorbonne vous faites un mémoire sur les
expressions stylistiques du mois dans
l'oeuvre de Benjamin Constant incroyable
oui j'avais un
vous avez un directeur de maîtrise qui
m'a dit tenez lisez Benjamin Constant et
dites moi ce qui vous apparaît il y a un
vrai travail chez lui de savoir si
effectivement il masque qui est la
personne réelle ou pas qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire qui s'exprime derrière le jeu
etc tout ça avec mon son très bien alors
à l'époque j'étais ami avec Olivier Nora
qui dirige les éditions grassées
maintenant Denis Oliven qui dirige le
groupe Lagardère tous les deux sont
anormales sup alors vous êtes très
impression évidemment en fait j'allais à
la bibliothèque à la Sorbonne ou à
Sainte-Geneviève et à Sainte-Geneviève
on voyait des gens de d'ailleurs qui
venaient aussi Normal Sup et puis
Olivier lui il venait faire un cours à
la Sorbonne après mon cours sur le Roman
de la Rose donc je le croisais à chaque
fois alors
j'étais quand même beaucoup dans l'amour
courtois etc donc on s'est connu comme
ça et après je les ai fréquentés c'est
toute une bande il vivait ensemble à
Saint-Cloud dans une maison alors il y
avait le frère de Denis Olivet François
Olivet et sa compagne Christine Scott
Thomas
vous avez 17 ans et moi j'adorais aller
chez eux comme ça et surtout j'étais
hyper complexée à l'époque de pas être
Normal Sup pas très agrégé parce que
quand on est là dedans on est quand même
mais il y avait vraiment sa sentait pas
du tout et j'étais plutôt ça les musées
presque parce que j'étais un peu un peu
décalé je faisais aussi d'autres choses
quoi alors à 18 ans pour pouvoir habiter
seul et payer vos études vous devenez
serveuse dans un salon de thé aux marais
et un jour un client un photographe vous
emmène à l'agence de mannequin élite
c'était un des premiers salés dans le
Marais d'athénois ça s'appelait donc il
y avait des gens qui venaient là qui
étaient un peu de New York d'ailleurs
enfin c'était un peu et on m'a proposé
non mais je suis petite enfin je vois
pas très bien si si pour ce qu'on
appelle des photos de beauté on a fait
la petite après dans la profession la
petite et voilà j'étais un peu
l'exception qui faisait la règle je fais
c'est des photos principalement de
de visage de bijoux de choses comme ça
quoi à partir de là vous allez mener une
vraie double vie donc mannequin qui
réussit très bien chez Elite les voyages
les boîtes la Night et étudiantes à la
Sorbonne comme parfaitement schizophrène
totalement surtout quand j'ai fait les
photos dans lui parce que donc on me
propose de partir avec Francis jacobetti
qui est quand même un excellent un
excellent photographe
jacobetti parce que vous aviez eu un
chagrin d'amour c'est à dire que
mon copain de l'époque le premier
raconte effectivement été sorti avec des
mannequins donc
bon que je me dis allez voilà ce sera le
truc donc je dis oui à ce truc et je me
retrouve à Bali et là on fait les photos
que je rentre je reprends mes études et
un jour j'arrive boulevard Saint-Michel
je vois sur le kiosque je me vois en
couvercle en couverture
tout je vais rue de l'École de médecine
il y avait un chinois qui vendait je dis
je prends lui comme ça à la peine un
articulant je laisse 10 francs et je
prends le magazine et je cours à mon
séminaire du professeur lartomas
génial donc je vais à mon cours et
l'entrecours je vais dans les toilettes
et vieux toilettes de la Sorbonne je
ferme et là me voilà feuilleté magazine
de lui et je tourne une page de page
trois pages 4 pages 11 pages et le
poster et là j'ai éclaté de rire j'étais
là et je trouvais ça drôle et voilà je
pense que cette image là elle est
représentative aussi de cette espèce de
with naïveté ou de c'est incroyable nuit
au bain douche et vos journées à la
Bibliothèque Sainte-Geneviève quoi c'est
c'était le contraste et je passais à
nous au bain douche pendant qu'un
bouquin à la main c'est comme je connais
pas de drogue j'ai jamais bu d'alcool je
m'ennuie un peu au bout d'un moment et
j'attendais Jonathan qui s'occupait de
la boîte donc j'attendais au kiné
j'étais un peu décalé alors 1984 fait un
casting pour une pub de Diane curry et
vous rencontrez un chanteur qui cherche
des choristes pour son premier
Champs-Élysées c'est Patrick Bruel il
vous propose d'être l'une des danseuses
de la chanson Marne de cette nana chez
Drucker qui fait la semaine suivante
quoi recoupe vol alors c'est d'autant
plus un coup de bol que en fait Patrick
il avait déjà ses trois danseuses
choristes qui avait fait les cœurs sur
le et puis une était malade il y avait
cette émission il était chez Diane curry
il faut que je trouve une fille pour
remplacer etc du bain regarde avec des
cassettes j'ai fait un casting et
regarde ça il me voit si c'est qui elle
s'appelle un tel bon personne ne
connaissait forcément il cherche partout
pour me retrouver ma sœur m'appelle un
jour me dit j'ai un copain qui a un
copain qui s'appelle Patrick Bruel qui
veut de voir on va au pastel le
restaurant à l'époque il arrive et en
fait ça s'est passé comme ça je vois ce
type arriver en plaqué qui vraiment
rempli l'espace quand il arrive quelque
part bonjour je m'appelle Patrick je
fais un émission etc je vous ai vu ça
vous dirait je vais regarder je dis oui
mais pour dire oui quoi parce que
j'avais un autre chagrin d'amour à
l'époque vraiment du rail je m'étais
mariée à 20 ans en fait et le type il
est parti trois jours après et donc j'ai
été un espèce de truc donc voir ça avant
mourir quoi c'était vraiment oui et donc
j'ai ce oui là a fait que j'ai remplacé
cette fille donc c'est pas moi qui
chante sur les disques j'imite à répéter
dans le salon et je passe à
Champs-Élysées voilà Champs-Élysées
c'est ce qui va faire basculer votre
destin parce que nouveau rebondissements
Michel Blanc qui vous a vu dans
l'émission vous propose une semaine de
tournage dans Marche à l'ombre vous
enchaînez quelques films et un jour vous
partez et tournez un film en Italie
pendant six mois avec là tu Ada avec
Anthony Delon là aussi je dirais que je
suis partie pour partir en Italie c'est
à dire j'avais fait j'avais fait ce film
donc tout à coup on m'appelle de partout
voulait être actrice ben non ah bon vous
étiez quoi mannequin oui enfin pour
payer mes études mes études ah bon vous
êtes une étudiante vous êtes une
intellectuelle non mais vous êtes
danseuse non j'ai pas fait de danse
j'avais pas trop à me propose en Italie
je dis allez je m'en vais et là j'habite
à Rome c'était génialissime je partais
le matin
à Chica dans la voiture va à pied antica
fastait superbe Fellini qui tournait à
côté voilà et donc je fais cette espèce
de voyage comme ça je tourne de film
là-bas et oui on a tourné sur le lac de
Côme premier film d'Anthony Delon donc
lui il était complètement à l'ouest donc
on était vraiment de naïf comme ça
là-dedans donc je fais ça mais presque
plus comme un voyage initiatique
personnel que pour penser à une
stratégie de faire telle ou tel film
donc je dirais qu'encore à ce moment là
j'ai toujours pas choisi de faire ça je
le fais parce que tout à coup ça ouvre
une porte sur un de l'inconnu et c'est
là que vous rencontrez un musicien
mondialement célèbre Manu catché ça
s'est passé comment en fait il a fait un
premier clip avec son groupe préface et
il voulait demander à différentes
actrices puisqu'à l'époque j'étais donc
devenue actrice de la génération de
faire un petit un petit apparition donc
son producteur m'a appelé je suis
arrivée sur le plateau et puis il me
parlait tout seul et je vais juste dire
on ferait de beaux enfants ensemble je
ne sais pas d'où c'est sorti mais c'est
sorti comme ça vous êtes capable de dire
des trucs pareils donc je l'ai choisi et
de ce jour-là on sait pas quitté pendant
des années vous partez 6 mois en tournée
avec lui et Peter Gabriel ce qui est pas
rien vous dites j'avais du fric j'ai
décidé de réussir ma vie affective être
femme et mère voilà et vous aurez deux
enfants ensemble et puis l'histoire
s'arrête parce que ça correspondait plus
à vos attentes et vous êtes quand même
assez prise d'absolu et quand ça
commence à être moins bien vous préférez
partir c'est-à-dire que par amour je
suis parti c'est à dire que je me
rendais compte que en fait ce que je
trouve de beau dans un couple c'est
d'aider l'autre quand même aller dans
des zones qui peut pas atteindre tout
seul et c'est vrai que Manu il a il a un
très très grand potentiel de création
et je n'avais pas envie d'être un espèce
de garde-fou la femme à la maison avec
les enfants etc donc j'ai suivi jusqu'au
Canada et après je lui ai dit et donc
c'était c'était de se dire je pense que
la vie que tu as amené en tout cas le
rôle que j'ai envie d'avoir c'est pas
celui-là et j'ai dit donc j'ai mis un
ça peut plus aller je veux Montréal vous
étiez installés
dans les bras pieds nus etc et lui c'est
un solitaire quand même
vous arrivez à Paris évidemment tout le
monde vous a oublié et là c'est une
suite de rebondissements incroyable de
vie vous rebondissez à la télé en
devenant pour France de la commissaire
Marie Saint-Georges dans le quai numéro
1 énorme succès populaire et je dis oui
là aussi pour une rencontre avec Pierre
grimbel producteur mais aussi avec
Daniel Thierry qui est la personne la
vraie commissaire qui a donné
l'idée de cette histoire et on commence
à tourner et là là aussi énorme succès à
l'époque ça fait un carton alors quelles
ont été une réaction de votre entourage
à ce moment-là devant cette célébrité
bien très bien maman elle a toujours
adoré me voir à la télé parce qu'elle a
l'impression du coup je suis proche
d'elle qu'elle me voit elle parle de moi
avec les gens voilà et puis mais sinon
les gens qui me connaissent bien ils
m'ont souvent dit mais oui mais quand
même est-ce que tu as vraiment envie
d'être actrice parce que c'est vrai que
finalement tous ces faits toujours comme
ça par des envies de tout à coup
fusionner avec des possibles avec et
c'est très instinctif et avec des décors
je me rends compte maintenant que c'est
beaucoup ça j'avais envie d'aller en
Italie j'avais envie là de tourner dans
des gardes se lever à 5h du mat on va
dans des gardes de triage on monte dans
des trucs on conduit des locomotives en
fait c'est plutôt ce que ça me fait
vivre dans l'immédiat au moment où je le
vis et le relationnel avec les gens que
l'image et l'effet que ça produit et
avec les médias ça s'est passé comment
très bien il y avait eu énormément de
médias au moment de marche avant tout ça
et puis après comme j'ai toujours
disons à partir du moment où j'ai eu les
enfants les médias ils voulaient faire
des photos avec les enfants tout ça je
voulais pas forcément donc il y a des
médias qui veulent plus et tout et là
pour quel numéro un bon c'était
c'est d'autres c'est un autre style de
média quoi quand on fait de la télé
c'est pas les mêmes médias effectivement
moi j'avais pas envie j'ai jamais aimé
le côté sacralisé et ce que j'aimais
bien dans la télé c'est que j'arrivais
chez les gens et j'avais l'impression
d'être dans quelque chose de beaucoup
plus
réaliste
c'était c'était bien ça m'a appuyé
surtout de pouvoir signer un contrat de
12 films ça m'aurait de pouvoir garder
les filles et
j'aurais pu resigner après et j'ai
décidé de pas resigner après où là
j'aurais pu demander ce que je voulais
et non j'avais envie de refaire du
théâtre donc
et l'amour alors cette célébrité vous a
apporté des rencontres amoureuses
[Musique]
de truc c'est que on approche pas
l'actrice toujours faire un peu des
problèmes si on est technicien faut pas
parce que si et ça si on est producteurs
machins en plus j'ai vécu une grande
histoire d'amour avec un au Signac qui
était mitter en scène et qui j'ai tourné
pas mal le film et du coup je me disais
je vais tourner avec lui parce qu'autant
tourner avec l'homme avec qui on est
alors les gens vous parlent pas trop si
vous connaissez metteur en scène une
espèce de truc on dirait que c'est pas
possible que ça ait vraiment ensemble et
je trouve non la célébrité isole
énormément ils ont beaucoup parce que
parce qu'en fait
l'amour je trouve ce qu'il y a de beau
dans la relation amoureuse c'est
vraiment ce qui a d'intime c'est d'être
dans la plus la partie la plus intime de
soi et donc si la personne vient vers
vous pour la partie la plus externe la
plus la plus estime voilà c'est souvent
des mauvaises raisons et ça dure pas
trop quel
était le meilleur moment de toute cette
époque là c'était quoi j'ai adoré
je suis Manu avec Peter Gabriel ça
c'était extraordinaire
tout autour du monde là après la
naissance des filles mais on sait
énormément amusé avec mes filles c'est à
dire qu'en fait j'ai choisi les films où
je faisais et tout ça pour pouvoir vivre
des moments sympas avec mes filles donc
je suis allée au Venezuela tourner une
pyrogue enfin j'ai fait plein de trucs
beaucoup de voyages et tout ça et le
grand luxe c'était pour avoir mes filles
avec moi donc ça c'est vraiment les
meilleurs moments c'est en fait de
fabriquer mon roman à moi de vie et le
pire moment bon j'ai dit j'ai une vraie
vraie fracture de ma vie comme mon père
est mort et c'est ça compte quand même
même si c'est pas quelque chose de
l'ordre professionnel mais on peut pas
faire voilà donc ça ça a été il y a eu
un vrai avant et après alors là vous
faites tout un tas de feuilletons avec
Arnaud Selignac fleur de sel voleur de
cœur l'été des hannetons
soit on tourne pas du tout soit
énormément et donc là je tournais
tellement que un jour je me suis dit bon
je tourne pour payer une baby-sitter qui
garde mes filles un truc qui me colle
pas quoi vous allez chercher les enfants
à l'école doit être contente les petites
parce qu'elle vous souvent de cette
espèce de truc comme ça on vous
déréalise complètement et il y a plus de
contact avec on a plus de vie sociale
finalement et c'est ça qui me faisait
souffrir en fait alors ensuite frais du
théâtre la politique
enfin c'est une vie incroyable oui parce
que je me suis dit il faut que je
revienne au texte et j'ai fait les
Monologues du vagin qui était vraiment
un texte puisque c'était un texte au
départ vraiment d'une journaliste qui
avait interviewer des gens etc donc moi
c'était la version d'une heure et demie
selon scène je fais ça et là je me rends
compte qu'en étant sur scène là je
commence à porter la parole d'autres
femmes et non pas à être Sophie Duez qui
est qu'on regarde ça m'intéresse pas
qu'on me regarde moi donc je fais ça et
là-dessus après j'étais à l'atelier de
Jospin j'ai rencontré de la Noé tout ça
et et tout à coup on s'intéressait à ce
que j'avais à dire à vous retourner à
Nice mais cette fois comme femme
politique donc je pars 40 ans avec mes
fils ouvrages je me dis je vais à Nice
quand même c'était pas je sais pas si on
m'a proposé une ville si je l'aurais
fait je m'installe là et là je suis
théâtre pendant cinq ans j'ai été là au
théâtre et de là je donne des cours dans
les collèges on y a des débats etc c'est
à dire que c'est l'actrice vraiment on
est salarié ne payait par mois et voilà
ça n'a plus rien à voir il y a personne
qui vient au premier de CSA donc le
matin quand je partais j'habite dans le
Vieux-Nice dans la vieille ville bonjour
boulanger etc tu fais quoi là-bas c'est
de chez coiffeur
on viendra te voir tout et je vais jouer
mon Tchekhov comme eux ils vont faire
leur peau et j'aime ce côté ouvrier de
l'artiste qui fait partie d'une ville
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous êtes
nostalgique de l'époque de marshallon de
quai numéro etc non pas du tout non je
suis pas nostalgique mais en fait j'ai
pas du tout une vision du temps
linéaire et avec il y a une chose s'est
passée et on avance comme ça vers un but
généralement une vision à certainement
mon côté circulaire que chez les Grecs
etc que c'est quelque chose constamment
donc j'ai mes l'intime perception que ce
que j'ai vécu existe encore dans un
autre cercle et je m'y transporte
excessivement facilement parce qu'en
fait je vis énormément par l'imaginaire
si c'était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous
ne referiez pas pareil
je prendrai beaucoup de choses moi je
suis au sérieux
j'essaierai d'être quand même un peu
plus légère
le jour vous allez mourir qu'est-ce que
vous les connaissent sur votre tombe
attention ça passe vite
ça va c'est très heureux de rallumer la
lumière soit ou Sophie et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu